expertos neerlandeses y japoneses buscan
descifrar un acertijo hasta ahora sin
solución el carguero ever given mantiene
bloqueada la circulación en el canal de
suez y aunque la empresa japonesa yo x
en propietaria del buque se ilusiona con
desencallarlo este sábado crece el temor
por que las tareas se extiendan incluso
por semanas el potencial es que esto se
magnifique si esto continúa durante un
largo periodo de tiempo en el peor de
los casos y se demora un mes en mover el
barco esto causaría una interrupción
masiva de la economía el canal de suez
es una de las rutas comerciales más
importantes del mundo sobre todo para el
traslado de petróleo y productos de
consumo como autopartes muebles o
textiles la obstrucción del barco que se
atascó en un banco de tierra como
consecuencia de fuertes vientos y una
tormenta de arena ha dejado cientos de
embarcaciones paralizadas las cuales
podrían ser desviadas por el sur de
áfrica esto añadiría casi 10.000
kilómetros a sus viajes con este
panorama ya se vislumbra un incremento
de precios
aunque los precios han aumentado
considerablemente en el último año por
la pandemia es inevitable que haya algún
efecto colateral en los
según los especialistas la firma
propietaria del ever given podría
enfrentar múltiples demandas por parte
de otras empresas en caso de que el
atasco dificulte sus operaciones una
posibilidad para la que yo hoy quise
dice estar preparada